We will now consider
an operation
that is, in some sense,
the opposite of merging.
We have a node, and traffic
arrives to that node.
And each time that we have
an arrival, we flip a coin.
And with probability
q, we send that arrival
to one particular stream.
And with probability
1 minus q, we
send the arrival
to another stream.
So we get two streams
that are formed
by taking the original
stream and splitting it
into two pieces.
And as an example,
these might be
arrivals at a department store.
And one stream
corresponds to the people
who go to the clothes section
of the department store,
whereas the other stream
corresponds to the people that
go to all of the other
sections of the store.
So let us now make our
model a little more precise.
We have a Bernoulli
process, which
is independent across time.
We also use an
independent coin flip
to deal with each
one of the arrivals.
But we will also make one
additional assumption, namely
that the Bernoulli
process is also
independent from the
process of coin flips.
With this assumption
in place, let us now
continue, and let
us draw a picture.
We have a Bernoulli
process with parameter p,
and arrivals get recorded
at certain times.
Each time that there is an
arrival, we will flip a coin.
And with probability
q, the arrival
will be sent to that stream.
With probability 1
minus q, the arrival
will be sent to
the other stream.
So one possible outcome
of the experiment
might be this one, where
these two arrivals were
sent to this stream and
sent to the top stream.
And we have these
probabilities q and 1 minus q
of sending the arrivals to
one or the other stream.
What kind of
process is this one?
We argue it is a
Bernoulli process.
First, we need to
check independence.
Here, the argument is more or
less the same as in the case
when we studied the
merging of processes.
For example, if we look at two
different slots and we ask,
how is the event at that slot
and at that slot determined?
Well, what happens in
this slot is determined
by whether we had
an arrival here
and what happened to the outcome
of the coin flip at that time.
What happens in this
slot is determined
by whether we had
an arrival here
and what happened to the
coin flip at that time.
Now, the coin flips
are independent
from the original
Bernoulli process.
And for either the coin flips
or the Bernoulli process,
we have independence
across time.
So all of the four random
variables involved here
that determine what
happens in these two slots
are independent of each other.
So what happens in
this slot is a function
of two random
variables here, which
are independent from the
two random variables that
determined what
happens in that slot.
So what happens in these two
slots are independent events.
And this argument goes
through more generally
when we consider
multiple distinct slots.
So this is the argument
for the independence
of the different slots in
this particular process.
And then during each
slot, what happens
is that we will have
an arrival if and only
if this process records
an arrival, which happens
with probability p, and
the corresponding coin
flip happens to send the
arrival in this direction, which
happens with probability q.
And so the conclusion
is that this process
is a Bernoulli process
with parameter p times q.
By a similar argument, the
other process that we obtain
will also be Bernoulli but with
probability p times 1 minus q.
And a final question--
are these two processes
that we get after the splitting
independent of each other?
This is a question
that we can answer
by reasoning intuitively.
If I tell you that there
was an arrival in this slot,
what can you infer from this?
Well, it tells me that
there was an arrival
in the original stream,
which was sent here.
But since it was sent
in this direction,
it means that it was not
sent in the other direction.
And so we do not have
an arrival in this slot.
Knowing that we
have an arrival here
means that we do not
have an arrival there.
So information about
one of the streams
gives us information about what
happened in the other stream.
And therefore, we do
not have independence.
So this is what happens when we
split two Bernoulli processes.
And earlier we saw
what happens when
we merge two independent
Bernoulli processes.
These two operations of
merging and splitting
are quite common in
constructing more complex models
using Bernoulli processes as
the elements of those models.
They are often useful models
either in transportation
systems, where you
have streams of traffic
that merge or split, also in
models of computer networks
or any other kind
of queueing system.
And these same operations
of merging and splitting
will also show up when we
study the continuous time
analog of the Bernoulli process,
namely the Poisson process.